مره جديده يحقق لهم ماستر رقما قياسيا هذه
المره
بخسارته اكبر ثروه سجلت في التاريخ 200
مليار دولار نعم الرقم صحيح ولكن الوضع
ليس شيئا الى هذه الدرجه فلا تزال قيمه
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا سبيس اكس
وتويتر تبلغ مئه وسبعه 137 مليار دولار
وهو جيد بما يكفي لا يحتل المركز الثاني
في قائمه اغنى اغنياء العالم
كان نموه ثروه الهن ماسك مدفوعا بالاساس
من حصته في تسلا بعد ان تجاوزت القيمه
السوقيه للشركه تريليون دولار لاول مره في
اكتوبر عام 2021 لتنضم الى الشركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه ابل ومايكروسوفت
وامازون
والقناص باللون
الاكبر في الانزلاق الذي قضى على حوالي
675 مليار دولار من القيمه السوقيه للشركه
هذا العام بل اضافه الى تغريدته المستمر
على تويتر وسلوكه غير المنتظم بشكل متزايد
بكل الاحوال قد يرتاد سهم تسلى ويمكن ان
يصبح ماسك مره اخرى اغنى شخص في العالم
ولكن سمعته باعتباره عبقريا تعرضت لبعض
الاضرار الجسيمه عام 2022 تقريبا بقدر
الضرر الذي تعرضت له ثروته الشخصيات لصباح
العربيه ريتا سليمان واشنطن
[موسيقى]